in the last video we set up this
definite integral to evaluate the volume
of the solid of revolution that we set
up using the shell method so now let's
just evaluate this thing so the main
thing is just simplifying this
expression I'll start off by trying to
simplify this part of it so that's going
to be y plus 1 I just need an Apple so
something we were just happened in my
throat but anyway that's done with y
plus 1 minus y squared minus 2y plus 1 I
just squared expanded out this binomial
and then that would simplify to another
Apple in my throat moment so that's
going to be y plus 1 minus y squared
plus 2 y minus 1 so this one and this
negative 1 cancel out and let's see you
get negative y squared plus 3y plus 3y
and then we're going to multiply that
we're going to multiply that times times
y plus 2 so when you multiply y plus 2
times this so you have Y times negative
Y squared gets us negative Y to the
third power y times 3y is going to be
plus 3y squared 2 times negative Y
squared is negative 2y squared and then
2 times 3 y is plus 6y so then you go
all the way down here this thing can
simplify to because you have 3y squared
minus 2 y squared so this is going to be
negative Y to the third
Plus this part right over here
simplifies to just Y squared plus y
squared plus 6y so that's this entire
part simplified simplifies to this town
here we can take the 2 pi out of the
integral sign so let's do that we're
integrating from Y is equal to 0 to Y is
equal to 3 dy and I took the 2 pi out
here and that is equal to our volume and
so now we're essentially ready to take
the antiderivative this is going to be
equal to 2 pi times the antiderivative
of this business evaluated at 3 minus
evaluated at 0
so the antiderivative of and I'll color
code it this is I found this useful this
is the antiderivative of y 2/3 is Y to
the 4th over 4 so this is negative y to
the 4th over 4 antiderivative of Y
squared is y to the third over 2 or Y to
the third over 3 I should say Y to the
third over 3 and then finally finally
I'll do it in yellow antiderivative of 6
y is 3y squared so plus 3y squared and
we are going to evaluate all of this
business at 2 0 and 3 so this simplifies
this is going to be equal to 2 pi times
well let's see let me do the same colors
3 to the fourth power is 81 so it's
negative 81 over 4 negative 81 over 4
plus let's see 3 2/3 27 divided by 3 is
9 plus 9 and then 3 squared is 9 times 3
is 27 plus 27 and then when you evaluate
all of these things at 0 you just get 0
so you're just subtracting out 0 so we
really don't have to do anything else
with the 0 and now we are ready to
simplify so this turns out to be let me
see this is going to turn out to be and
actually actually let's just add them
all up so this is going to be 9 plus 27
is 36 so that is 36 and if we want to
add it to negative 81 over 4 we have to
find a common denominator so all of this
business is going to be equal to 2 pi
times and so our common denominator can
be 4 times something over 4 we have
negative 81 over 4 and then 36 times 4
is 144 is that right yep that's 144 so
36 times 4 is so it's plus 144 30 times
4 is 120 plus another 24 is 144 so you
have 144 essentially minus 81 so this is
going to be equal to 2
pi times that actually I can even
simplify it a little bit more we have a
2 here and a 4 there so divide the
numerator and the denominator by 2 so
you get over 2 so you're going to have
pi times let's see this is going to be
44 let's see if this was an 80 this
would be 64 right that would be 64 so
it's going to be 63 so it's going to be
63 let me write this way it's going to
be 63 pi 63 PI over 2 did I do that
right 60 plus 81 is 141 add another 3 to
144 yep and we're done we figured out
the volume of our front of jet engine
looking shape